abone ol
bu iki hafta kaldı bu ülkenin sistemi
değişecek mi değişmeyecek mi
bu şunun şurasında 15 gün sonra Umuyorum
ki hepimiz Sandığa gideceğiz ve uyumlu
vereceğiz hepimizin şu anda Bu salonda
bulunan 2bin küsür kişinin kafasında
eminim acaba ne çıkacak vardır bırak ama
bir o kadar da eminim herkesin olmasa
bile asgari yüzde sekseni kafasında Peki
ya benim istediğim sonuç çıkmazsa ben bu
ülkeyi terk mi edeyim
bu burada bu kalayım sorunsalı geziyor
dur Kimimiz Diyoruz ki ya falanca ülkede
500 bin euro verdiğinde on yıl oturma
izni veriyorlar bir filanca ülkeye git
ev al orada vatandaşlık veriyorlar ki ya
Bu yaştan sonra ne evi arkadaşlar başka
yerde yaşayamam En iyisi ben çocukları
yollayayım onlar kapağı atsın kapağı
atmak
eve gitmek mi Kalmak mı
O çok büyük sorunsalı şu anda bu ülkenin
yok ama sadece şu anda değil tarih
boyunca da büyük bir sorunsalı olmuş
aslında bu topraklar Bir göç yatağa
belki nihai vatan oldu bizlere ama aynı
zamanda bir göç yatağa doldu Binlerce
yıl öncesinden Göçebe Kavimler geldiler
buralara yerleştiler buralardan gittiler
geçtiler aynı zamanda bu ülkede hem el
salladı gidenleri ne hem de bir taraftan
hoş geldin dedim belki de beyinlerimizin
kuranderde kalması bu yüzdendir ki
kapıda açık çünkü genelde yani şöyle
gözlerinizi kapatın isterseniz siyah
beyaz günlere gidelim Fotoğraf kullanmak
istemedim çünkü hakikaten içimden
gelmedi iki hafta sonra düşündüğümden
gözünüzü kapatın şöyle 1949'da götüreyim
ben sizi siyah beyaz Dolmabahçe
Sarayı'nın önüne hayalin Hoca değil
Bu bir sevinç bir alkış Bir Çığlık Anam
ne oluyor diye bakıyorsunuz Sanayi
devriminden Yıllar yıllar sonra üstüne
üç kuşak olmuşş ülkeye ilk traktör
geliyor
O çok güzel yani sanayileşmeye karşı
değiliz tamam büyük bir sevinçle
karşılandı ve bağrına basıldım traktör
Ama öyle olmadı Çünkü bunun negatif
tarafları da oldu köylere gidildiğinde
bu traktör de pek çok işçi traktör
yüzünden işsiz kaldı
bu ne yaptılar Taşı Toprağı Altın
dedikleri şehre geldiler
ve onların gelişiyle beraber Tabii ki
onlar sorumlu değil onlar karınlarını
doyurma derdinde onların gelişiyle
beraber rant kavramı girdi hayatımızı
baç Çünkü evleri olanlar artık daha
fazla kira ister oldular satmak için çok
daha fazla paralar ister oldular arsalar
pahalandı E ne yaptı bu insanlar
gecekondu kurdular Çünkü bir damara
yaşındaydılar
bu çarpık kentleşme
bu iş ve işçi bulma kurumu önündeki uzun
kuyruklar bozulan sağlık eğitim sistemi
İşte bunlar bir traktörün bu ülkeye
girmesiyle kendini gösterdi ve o günden
bugüne hala çarpık şehirleşmenin
kurbanları Hisset beraber bugün buraya
gelirken yaşadığınız trafik çilesi de
bunun bir Aslında parçası bu kadar
küçümseme elim 1 milyon kişi köyden
kente göç etti ama o zaman Türkiye'nin
nüfusu Bu beş yılda oluyor 50-55 yılları
arasında 21000000 yani 21'de birimiz göç
etti ve çoğunuz o köyde durum onları el
salladım
Bu Gelini 1960 biri yine hatırlarsınız o
karayı sizin hayalinizde bırakıyorum
Hani Sirkeci garından trenlerden bizim
durup el sağladığımız kare vardı ya
Almanya'ya geçen işçilerimiz Çünkü bir
kısmının karnı hala duymamıştım hala
ekmek arayışındalar da ve kasabasındaki
görmeden bir başka dilin konuşulduğu
bambaşka bir yere gitti
ve o da bin 961 bin 974 yılları arasında
13 yılda 1 milyon kişi Göçtü Bugün 3
milyon Türk yaşıyor Almanya'da gelelim
1980'e bir darbe yaşandı Türkiye'nin
kara tarihi-i ve orada işkence görmemek
adına hapse düşmemek adına buradan kaçan
pek çok entellektüel Aydın ve sanatçı
vardı çoğu Avrupa'ya birçoğu da Kuzey
Avrupa'ya yerleşti bizimle durduk ve
onlara el sağladık ve resmi rakamlara
göre 35000 ama Birleşmiş Milletler'e
göre 105.000 aydınımız Ülkeyi terk etti
kaçtılar kaçmak zorunda kaldılar ve tabi
her zaman el sağlayan olmadık bazen de
kapıyı açıp hoş geldin dedik bu ülke çok
kişiyi misafir etti 1917 yılında
bolşevik devriminden kaçan uluslar
buraya sığındı
bu İki Dünya Savaşı öncesinde Hitler
poşetinden kaçan Almanlar buraya sığındı
Hitler'in işgal ettiği ülkelerden kaçan
avusturyalılar buraya sığındı Bosna
Hersek savaşında Boşnaklar Bulgar
soydaşlarımız Afgan mülteciler buraya
sığındı ve son olarak da Suriyeliler şey
gitmek öyle bir eylemdir ki gitmeyi
düşündüğünüz zaman rahat olmayı
isterseniz spor ayakkabınızı değil mi
yüz pabucunu Giyer gidersiniz böyle
bavulunuzu çekersiniz havaalanına
gidersiniz ama kaçtığınız zaman
ayağınızda ne olduğuna bakmazsınız
Suriyeliler için de öyle oldu çoğu
çıplak ayaklı bir kısmı terlikleriyle
çocuklarını kalktıkları gibi bir de
yanlarına salça bidonlarını alarak Çünkü
bir ekmek bulduğunuzda Karnınızı onunla
doldurabilirsiniz ve uzun süre
saklayabilirsiniz o salçayı kaçtılar
Türkiye 3000000 suriyeliyi misafir
ediyor şu anda onların Bir Milyonu çocuk
ve o
bu yarısı eğitim görmüyor
var ama biz onlara kapımızı açtık Öyle
ya da böyle beğenin ya da beğenmeyin O
zaman bu soruyu şöyle de sormak
gerekiyor gitmek mi Kalmak mı yoksa
gitmek mi kaçmak mı
Ama ben buna çok geç karar verebilmiş
birinci benim hayatımın büyük bölümü
bu oturup böyle durup gidenlere Elsa
Ağlamakla Geçti Ben böyle kaldım 18
yaşındaydım aynı evde yaşıyorduk
Anneannem öldü bir eyalet bir çocuktu
o ölüsünü görmek istedim Çünkü
vedalaşmak istedim onu el sallamak
istedim annem de benim kadar gelişmiş
bir yanına götürdüm ve bana öğretti dedi
ki bak önce bir öldüğünde yüzünü
kapatsın sonra kendisini buradan bir
eşarpla bağlarsın ki çenesi düşer ölümün
dedi sonra ayakların Baş parmaklarını
birbirine bağlarsın dedi
ne gösterdi sonra da biliyorsan duasını
okursun dedi
bu Belki kendi ölümüne hazırlık ediyordu
sonra kansere yakalandı Annem Türkiye'de
ömrü yok dediler babam varını yoğunu
satıp annemi Londra'ya götürdü Ve dört
yıl yaşata bildim 12 yaşındaydım annemi
kaybettiğinde çok yanına gitmek ve ona
vedalaşmak isterdim ama babam ve
Arkadaşları travmatik olabileceğini
benim için düşündüklerinden annemi
göstermediler E ben Yıllar Boyunca
Annemin bir gün geri döneceğini
Diğerleri de yaşadığını hayal ettim
sonra 18 yaşına geldim Hay ben de
Acıların Çocuğu gibi anlatıyorum hafta
yeter bir anlatınca insanın fena geliyor
ama öyle ve 18 yaşına geldim babaannem
öldü babam yurt dışı seyahat dedi
babaannemle aynı evdeydik uyandığımda
onun ölüsünü buldum
o uykusunda öldüğünü diliyorum hala en
güzel ürünlerden biri olduğunu
düşünüyorum kimse yoktu Ben bana
öğretildiği gibi gözümü kapattığım
kendisini bağladım ayaklarını bağladım
ve başında duasını okudum sonra babamın
arkadaşlarını arayıp Morga
kaldırılmasını sağladı Babam gelene
kadar sonra babamı kaybettim en
ambulansla götürüldüğü için bir kalp
krizi idi onunla ancam orta vedalaş a
bildim yanına girdim elini tuttum
kulağına seni seviyorum dedim ve ona da
yine eş salladım Deniz mahkum
istiyorsanız sallamayın Hayat size bunu
zorla yaptırıyor zaten sonra
Ve içimden dedim yeter artık bende
gitmeliyim birileri de benim arkamdan el
sallamadı ve o sırada eşim ne orada bir
iş buldu O gidince ben de uzun yıllardır
çalıştığım TRT den istifa etti mi gittim
200 metrekarelik bir evde yaşıyorum'
Ankara'da o Bolu hazırlamak çok
travmatik Tea Çünkü o gün karar verdim
yıl 2003'te
bu iki tane bavulla gideceğim ve içinde
sadece giysilerim olacak bütün çatalı mı
bardağımı kanepe mi Sevdiğim bütün
eşyaları bir büyükelçinin 3. katibe sine
Kiraya verdim
Bu bir küçücük bir eve gecekondudan
bozma yatağı kırık çarşafı delik bardağı
kırık Londra'da Çünkü paramız ona
yetiyor Çünkü zaten Hayat Orada öyle mi
imal yerleştik yedi yıl yaşadım
Londra'da ve yine 2010 yılında burun
gökten teklif gelince Bloom bölgede
gelmek üzere Bir bavulla Türkiye'ye
geldi ve 2003 yılından bu yana sadece
bavula yaşıyorum eşya alıyorum mobilyalı
evlerde oturuyorum Çünkü bir kere
hareket etmeye ve ev sağlamaya
başladığını zaman ve dağları alıştığınız
zaman o kanepenin o çatalın o Bıçağın
size sanal kökler yarattığını
görüyorsunuz Bir kanepe ya da bir ev ya
da bir daha benim kökü olmamalı benim
gerçek kökü Madem ki onları zaten
kaybettim Sonra Eşimin de arkasından el
salladım veda ettim sonuç itibariyle o
zaman bir eşya benim kökü olmamalı diye
düşündüm ve bavulumda yaşamaya karar
verdim hani
bu aranızdaki im ojeler var ya onlardan
biri misiniz Bir tane kırmızı balon
vardır O benim işte kendimi ona çok
benzetiyorum helyumla doldurulmuş ve
Alttan iki var Ayakta tek başına duruyor
kökü de yok gidebilirdi ama kalmayı
seçiyor Esma ile tanıştırayım Siz sekiz
yaşında ve genelde Gezi Parkı'nda
yaşıyor o da kendine bir Eğitim Yuvası
bir dam arayışı içinde burada var olmaya
çalışıyor ve çöpten bulduğu bu topuklu
ayakkabılardan herhangi birimizin artık
beğenmeyerek attığı topuklu
ayakkabılarla belki de kadın olmak Belki
de güzel hissetmek Belki de bastığı yere
artık sağlam düşünerek kendi istediği
gibi yüksekten basabilmek için bunlarla
poz veriyor birinden hoşlanıyor da 8
yaşındayım onu yaşında mı başka bir
kızla var sekiz yaşından o çocuklar
hoşlandığı için aralarına girmeyi tercih
ediyor Esma'nın hikayesi böyle beni
sekiz yaşında anneannemi kaybettiğim
güne götürdü ben
o okullarında yaşamayı tercih ediyorum
Çünkü ben gitmeyeceğim arkadaşlar Çünkü
ben buraya Hayallerim içinde öldüm Çünkü
ben Londra'ya Hayallerim için gittim
çünkü ben buraya dönmek için gittim
çünkü ne yazık ki çifte standart mıyız
Ben Ankara'dan istediğiniz kadar
başarılı olur İstanbul'a gelseydin
muhabir olarak ya da televizyoncu olarak
bu kadar havalı getirilmeyecek tek
Londra üstünden geldiğim zaman bir
şaşaalı geldim ki sormayın sanki çok
acayip bir geliyor altı üstü yaptığımız
hiç belli ama böyleydi Ve ben gerçekten
hem dünya insan olabilmek için hem
dünyayı tanıyabilmek başka kültürler
görebilmek için ama hiç değilse bir kere
el sağlayabilmek için ben de gidiyorum
diyebilmek için dünyaya gittim ve hayal
ettiğim gibi bu sahnede olmayı bu işi
yapmayı hayal ediyorum Hala da
hayallerim var mesela bütün kadınlara
ekonomiyi sevdirmeyi hayal ediyorum bunu
gerçekten Çünkü kadınlar ekonomi
ne gelirse bu ülke kurtulur onu biliyor
mesela mesela yaşlıların kimsesiz
çocukların ve Sokak hayvanlarının
birbirinden zincirleme sorumlu olacağı
bir köy kurmak istiyorum ölmeden önce
çünkü hepsinin birbirine sahiplenmeye
ihtiyacı olduğunu düşünüyorum şu Sorum
şu size şimdi gitmek mi Kalmak mı değil
siz karar verin gitmek mi kaçmak
bu çünkü kaçmak hiçbir zaman Bir Hayal
olamaz hele de istediğiniz ya da
istemediğiniz bir yönetim var diye
Burada azınlığa düştü mü düşünerek
Bu Bir Başka ülkede azınlığın da yazılı
olup olmayacağımızı bilmeden Belki de ki
Daha bugüne kadar elinizi dahi
değiştirmediğiniz Bir Hayatta kaç watt
Bir Hayal olamaz Evet caz şarkıcısı
olmak istiyorsunuz ve dünya çapında
olmak istiyorsunuz dur gidin New Orleans
Aha çok iyi bir makine mühendisi olmak
için yedin almaya hep beraber gidelim
ama İstediğiniz bir şeyler istediğiniz
gibi gitmiyor diye gitmekse Eğer bütün
hayaliniz o zaman dönüp aynaya bakalım
yani bakalım gerçekten gidiyor muyuz
yoksa biz kaçıyor muyuz ya da kurduğumuz
Hayal kaçmak üzerine mi
bu Vallahi ben bana fikrimi sorarsanız
naçizane hiçbirimizin kafasına girip
Hiçbir şey diyemem haddim değil ama ben
beni bırakmayın derim şöyle Kim bu benim
işte
ve bu uçan balon değil emojideki uçan
balon
ama gittiğiniz takdirde giderseniz ki
Çünkü bu salondaki mm 20 kişi Eğer
buraya Bizi dinlemeye geldiyseniz de
size konuşma yapmaya çıktıysa qbeez bu
memlekette birbirimize emanetiz demektir
bir Eğer giderseniz Eğer giderseniz
bunun içindeki helyum olmaz Siz benim
helyum unuttunuz Biz de sizin her yıldız
Biz birbirimizin her you muyuz bunu
havaya kaldırmak için bunu düz
tutabilmek için
mı Yoksa böyle Hakikaten bu balon böyle
kalacak ve ben hiçbirinizin arkasından
el sallamak istemiyorum hiçbirinize
hiçbir yere artık bu yaştan sonra
göndermek istemiyorum hele hele buraya
gelecek ve güneşli bir cumartesi burada
birlikte geçirecek bu değerli insanların
kaçmasını hiç istemiyorum Çünkü kaçmayı
hiçbirimize yakıştırıyorum o